hi how's it going good how's it going
with you
going so good the glasses look great by
the way thanks i
need them apparently falling apart i've
always wanted them just so like you know
anyways this is exciting i want to know
who in your household
i mean other than yourself is actually
the most excited that you are
in the mcu now officially your face in
there
i mean i think right now i think it's my
my
husband and my daughter i think my fort
my my
son who's a little older is excited is
very excited but i will never know it
carlos he will never let mom know no
because your mom your mom is never cool
that's just like the rule of law like
you just you can't have a cool mom so he
just can never let me see it but i i
think he's excited
you have to find out that and out in
other ways like he talks to a friend
i could never straight up ask him
because he'd be like i mean but then
i would think that he's excited another
way he just he just can't tell me
so what does that mean what was that
sorry
i respect it respect it absolutely
so what's the prep like for going into
uh
into the press rounds for this because
you know now you've got
all these secrets and everyone like
pressed like me they want to know
and like nerdy fans like me they think
they know
so you know going in how do you prep
yourself for
i know what i'm going to say and then
obviously what i can't say
you know i mean i have this at the ready
that i just go like this
when i can't say anything and then also
like i would just say
you know just go for the ride like
everyone wants to know
everything which i totally appreciate
but then there's also really a lot of
fun in the patience of it and like
and i i i um
[Music]
you know there's so i know how many
theories there are and how many like
there's just so much which
is so exciting like i've never this is
my first time in the mci
mcu and so i was like everyone was like
get ready because there's going to be a
lot of theories
and i was like whoa there really are but
i would just say
i as my as a newbie i would just be
i would just would hope people would be
like willing to just like
go for the ride and be surprised
so when someone says to you like have
you read the theory about the fact that
you're actually agatha harkness
and you're going to be abc exposure you
just grab that glass and
i'm like honey i'm the nosy neighbor who
lives next door
who is in there who is in their
neighborhood as a confidant
of wanda to guide her through
the michigan which is life in this new
neighborhood
i love it yeah
so you know when uh traditionally
property is brought over from like
between movies to tv we don't get to see
the characters
cross over but now marvel's breaking the
rules with all this how excited are you
about the fact that the mcu now includes
not just stuff that you would see
in the big screen but you know you guys
are essentially kicking off
the next chapter that's crazy i know
i mean i still can't believe i mean i
think i just i mean
i really still can't believe that my
entrance to the mcu is
in a 50s sitcom walking through that
door like it's so bananas
but i i mean i i think that this is also
like a way to get to know like and how
it was pitched to me also was like
this is a way to get to know characters
that in the big mcu
movies you wouldn't we we just haven't
had a chance
to they just haven't had room or time to
really dig down
deep into and so i mean i remember
seeing these movies with my kids
and being like what's happening with
those two about wanda and vision because
there's so there was such a spark there
and so much real
i feeling and i i wanted to know more i
also want to know more
more about wanda and so this is a chance
to like
take the time to get to know these
people that we have seen on the screen
for maybe not as much time as we would
have liked to have
and um also it will feed as kevin has
said like this will
inform this next this next phase in many
many ways
all these shows will so it's really
exciting and also like
you know i i think a really valuable
and important way to do it there's a lot
of eyeballs
yeah well i think the i want more is the
sentiment of the day because as far as
the press goes i think three episodes
for us was not enough and it's going to
be hard to wait for the next one so i
mean thank you for this thank you for
your time today
of course yeah thank you really nice
meeting you